What would the DOM be like without CSS?
Well, as you can see here with the sample page that you've been using,
it's pretty boring.
But luckily, you can access and modify CSS with jQuery pretty easily.
Now, you should be careful because changing CSS with JavaScript or
jQuery means adding inline CSS.
See, right here it says that jQuery modifies the element's style property.
This isn't a good way of building a site, but sometimes it's needed.
In this lesson, we'll use it, but in the real world, you should always think
about whether you should solve your problem with CSS or jQuery.
The .css( ) method is similar to the .adder( ) method that we just saw.
One method signature will get the value of the CSS property,
while another signature will set the value of the CSS property.
Using .css, can you set the font size of all the article-items to 20 pixels?